[Applaudissements]
vous nous avez fourni des
enregistrements sonores hyper flippant
vous avez enregistré ce qui se passait
chez vous ouais et on a même une vidéo
on va regarder c'est ce qu'on appelle de
la transe communication instrumental
c'est-à-dire oles on vit normalement on
va là on laisse un enregistreur tourner
un dictaphone n'importe quoi et après on
réécoute et on a des voix qui en fait
n'ont pas la même fréquence que nos voix
c'est comme ça qu'on reconnaît que c'est
des voix alors une équité qui croit
aussi au tour notamment antoine ahua je
suis allé au château de fougères est
donc c'est vraiment oui oui je peux
porter un témoignage c'est assez direct
alors passé c'est très effrayant un bon
p'tit déj un bon p'tit déj
oui j'ai vraiment eu la trouille moi
vous avez vous avez entendu des voix
vous avez senti de la world on a fait
cet exercice et puis on avait fait aussi
un jeu de ouija avec donc et les entités
de l'au delà qui doit se manifester et
répondre à des questions qu'on leur pose
et moi j'ai eu quand même un contact
assez privilégiés avec une de ces
entités
on lui a demandé si elle avait un
message personnel pour moi on a attendu
et puis finalement ça s'est dessinée
chez on a entendu la voix qui m'a dit ok
dingue
[Applaudissements]
non c'était madame supporters
marseillais
vous êtes en anglais mais je n'ai pas
d'actions non ou oui je pouvais vous a
dit oui mais justement c'est bien fait
pour toi
je trouve cet album est donc posée non
c'est un outsider vous êtes
tranquillement je suis en train de faire
une omelette reculait de poule à